there is some kind of fake church
somewhere
and actually there are a lot of fake
churches that have been doing this
you've seen a lot of clips of this I've
even heard stories of this anecdotally
from
people I know who know of these churches
or who even attend these churches that
will invite drag queens in
to preach a kind of
transvestite pseudo-gospel specifically
two kids this is one that's just been
going viral over the last few days
do you have any questions for Miss
Pentecost
oh thank you yeah you like her eye
shadow that's great yeah yeah maybe
she'll let you borrow it when you're
older when you're allowed to wear makeup
yeah
of course
yeah
well one of the things I think is great
about Miss Pentecost is she reminds us
that we we follow a God who calls us to
not conform to things of this world uh
that we're supposed to be transformed by
the renewal of our minds and that means
that what I think today may have to
change tomorrow if I continue to renew
my mind and it's so cool that we serve a
God that calls us to continue to grow
and continue to to change into something
new
uh this is horrifying for many many
reasons but I will tell you
just as a sort of not a defense
but it just in all fairness to that drag
queen who calls himself
Miss penny cost so just this this
sacrilegious mockery of the Pentecost
when the the Holy Spirit descends and
makes so many thousands of disciples
I am much less offended by the guy who
puts on a dress and pretends to be a
woman
than I am by the other guy next to him
who dresses up and pretends to be a
priest
the man is obviously not a valid priest
I don't know which heretical systematic
sect of Christianity this is I I read
somewhere it was some version of
methodism but uh whatever who knows you
know some obviously gone completely
insane heretical
Blasphemous systematic sect of
Christianity
that's preaching an anti-gospel just
completely the opposite of Christianity
but worth pointing out too
Christ speaks very specifically in the
gospel about what that priest is doing
and what that transvestite is doing too
but but more so the priest and it's it's
a verse of the Gospel that is frequently
invoked in
in the transiting the kids debate or
especially in the abortion debate where
he says you know uh the people who lead
the littlest ones astray
it would be better for them to have
millstones tied around their necks that
that is basically the effect of what
will happen if you lead the little ones
astray who who offends the least of of
these people and it the verses often
misinterpreted to mean people who just
you know go out and smack a kid or abuse
a child or you know kill a baby in the
womb or something like that but it it's
the verse is not really speaking about
you know beating a child the verse is
speaking about the sin of Scandal
leading someone astray causing someone
to stumble that's what the priest is
doing
and it's a it's an absolutely horrifying
scene obviously and no one should attend
that ridiculous church and the priest
should get another job and beg
forgiveness from God
but it shows you what leftism does it
ties in forgetting the religious
question for putting it aside for a
second it shows you what leftism does
leftism goes into every Institution
and cuts it open like the opening scene
of The Empire Strikes Back and pulls out
the guts of that thing and then crawls
inside and starts to animate it like
night night of the living dead that's
what it does
and it does it with Priestly a tie or it
does it with the churches it does with
the universities it does it with our
systems of government and it creates a
kind of a show a deceit
a sock puppet theater
of our public institutions of our
politics and I when I say politics I
don't just mean Schoolhouse Rock You
Know Capitol Hill and everything I'm
talking about all of the Power centers
that we have the the businesses the the
universities the classrooms all of it it
goes in and it makes a kind of show of
everything
and it often pretends that there's even
political opposition but there's not
there is just ultimately the kind of
uniparty and it's leading people to be
deeply distrustful of the established
institutions this is what is leading
Tulsi gabbard to to fall away from the
Democrat Party it's what's leading a lot
of trump supporters to say look I like
Trump I want to make America great again
I'm conservative I'm right wing but I'm
not some establishment Republican I
disagree with the Republican
establishment on many if not most issues
okay I guess I'm just something
different I'm just a crazy guy
who doesn't want to kill the babies
doesn't want to trans the kids wants to
waive the American flag wants to have
actual borders doesn't want to engage in
adventurism overseas and lead to nuclear
Armageddon I call me crazy that's just
what I
that's just me
and a lot of people are there
I bet a plurality of the people are
pretty much somewhere right around there
if not an outright majority of the
people
and increasingly as as the liberal
establishment doubles down right
whenever people question the liberal
establishment's power what do they do
they start putting up big fences and
barricades and barbed wire in Washington
D.C what does the liberal establishment
do they start censoring you they kick
you off social media they de-platform
you they take your money out of PayPal
they freeze your accounts they arrest
you they investigate you in some cases I
mean they're really getting much more
aggressive they call parents domestic
terrorists for questioning what their
kids are learning in schools they call
half the country semi-fascists they're
really really tightening their grip
right now in power and so you're going
to see this debate as we move into 20
the end of 2022 2023 2024. the battle is
not going to be Republican versus
Democrat necessarily
even really left versus right exactly
you're going to see a battle in this
cracking up of what has been understood
to be the American system in recent
years which is liberal democracy it's
going to be that crack up there and it's
going to be a debattle but between the
liberalism and the Democracy pick a side
the rest of the show is continuing now
in the members block it is work
Wednesday and so my producer Ben Davies
has teed up a new challenge for me it is
from the channel love don't judge and
the challenge is to see how long I can
just totally simply merely love without
any kind of judgments whatsoever
creeping into my head I'm not sure how
long I'm going to make it if you are not
a member click the link in the
description and join us we will see you
on the member block
[Music]
foreign